being scared is a superpower well I
tried to get some guidance by asking on
Twitter what I should do for my next
list and pretty much everyone who
respond to give me a different answer so
heck oh that I'm doing my own choice so
seems as this is October let's go with
picking my picks for the top 10 scariest
Doctor Who episodes now I expect this
list to be heavily argued I think there
are a few things more subjective than
what scares you with the possible
exception of what makes you laugh and
hey guess what list I'm gonna do next
but in any case when I say these are the
scariest episodes I'm not talking about
episodes with these scariest moments or
the scariest you know single scenes I'm
talking about a pervasive important
element of the episode that I personally
found scary and do remember this is a
personal ranking which means there are
some things that I personally find more
scary than others that may not be the
case for you I absolutely feel that the
top 10 that I have picked for our good
solid picks the order in which I'm
ranking them that I think is probably
where I'm gonna get a bit more are you
in but that's enough preamble let's get
right into it with number 10 hide this
is an episode a lot of people seem to
have forgotten about but I actually
rather like and the presentation of it
as setting it up as a haunted house and
how sort of disjointed and creepy the
monsters until we get a good look at it
I think they show it a bit more clearly
than they should have but the way it
moves and the fact that the doctor
himself gets scared outright and not
just like in the moment over run down
the corridor like he's scared and says
as much and that's not something we see
very often I think that adds to the feel
of it as well and it's just got a lot of
really good kind of gothic atmosphere it
doesn't quite get as deep into the fear
as some of the ones above it which is
why it's occupying the number 10 spot
but I think it's a I think in general
it's a better episode than its given
credit for and especially when you look
at it in terms
scary episode number 9 silence in the
library and forest of the Dead now part
of me really wanted to put the this
two-parter up higher and I suppose this
is your reminder I do count two parters
there's only one story and the reason I
couldn't is as much as I loved this
story and it's one of my favorites of
all time the fear element while good is
also not the best thing about it and
there are other episodes that I do find
scarier but shadows that eat you that's
that's unnerving and it also does
something that I really really enjoy
which is that not every shadow is a
problem but any shadow could be and that
uncertainty I think is really important
and a big part of what makes it work as
well as it does it's not just fear of
the dark it's the fear of not knowing
like maybe I could run through the
shadow and be fine or maybe it'll be the
death of me I don't know so I generally
find that more frightening and unnerving
that sense of uncertainty as opposed to
being certain well if I do that I will
die is like maybe I will and that means
that this choice that I make to do that
thing or to not do that thing carries
much more consequence to it and it is
very possible to make the wrong choice
and have never had a chance to know
otherwise and there's some additional
nice little creepy moments to the faces
and the in the computer thing that's not
a bad touch either and it's I mean I
just love this episode anyway but I do
think that the abashed of Narada are a
good example of a nice scary monster
number eight listen listen is an episode
that I'm gonna have to do a deeper dive
into one of these days because it's an
episode that I think less of the more
time passes but I do think that when
this episode is working it's working
great I love the upfront premise of it I
love the doctor talking about this thing
that is always hiding is perfect hiding
and it's always right there but you can
never truly see it and I like that we
don't and we don't even get a 100%
confirmation that this thing exists or
that it's just some obsession that
the doctor has latched on to we don't
really get a confirmation either way and
I like that as well there's just some
great scenes with the with the form
under the sheet in Danny's room the the
scene it like at the end of time words
like there's no one left
so who's knocking outside I mean that's
as one of the classic sort of writing
exercise prompts the last man on earth
is inside an empty house and there's a
knock at the door there was a time when
I probably would have put this in the
top five if not top three but
unfortunately revisiting it there are
aspects that don't work for me and
honestly as much as I love his initial
setup and explanation of the thing the
doctor talks too much
there are moments especially in the
bedroom with young Danny that would have
sat so much better been so much more
tensity it just stopped talking for a
bit but I still think that when the when
the tension is properly rationed in this
episode that is really unnerving and now
we're gonna move up to the one that I
know is the one I'm gonna get a lot of
heat for not putting higher number seven
waters of Mars now I've talked about
waters of Mars before and my feelings on
it I did a video just about that so I
wouldn't have to keep explaining to
people why Wow I do enjoy this episode
I'm not in love with it the way so many
people are now this is a good scary
episode and I the whole image of you
know the black mouth and the crack that
I mean that's a good scary image and it
yo the way it the way it spreads works I
really like the progression of it in
that one woman who's put in quarantine
and so at first you're like maybe it
doesn't take over right away even later
you find out it does and it really does
a great job I'd created a real sense of
foreboding around the water so why am I
not putting it higher on the lists to be
blunt about it the flood basically play
out as zombie analogs and I'm kind of
over zombies and zombies have never been
especially scary to me in the first
place so it's good and I get why people
love this episode I get why people are
scared by it it's just this is where the
subjective thing that I talked about
comes in which is that what it is
playing up as scary is not particularly
inherently scary to me other stuff is
that stuff's gonna be higher that's what
happens number six the impossible planet
and the satan pit no it's not because
the thing the devil is an inherently
scary figure it can be if played right
but ultimately this is just about the
way certain moments are built up that
scene where the voice is talking to Toby
and it's saying yo I'm right behind you
don't turn around if you turn around
you'll died like that's weird and
unnerving and nothing would ever talk
like that inside this disturbing voice
and you really you feel like you're
sitting in the seat where Toby is
sitting there like oh my god what would
I do
that's a wonderfully tense scene and
there's just a great thread through the
whole thing and I play a big part of why
I think this one works is it actually
under plays the score really factors
into this doctor who can get a little
bombastic with his score sometimes it's
completely under played here it's a very
melancholy score it actually reminds me
a lot of the soundtrack from Firefly at
times but just the moments like when
possessed Toby is standing out in the
vacuum of space just grinning like
that's unnerving and then of course we
have the OOD when they all go red in the
eyes and when this thing's just you see
the impact of the things that the Beast
says has on each of the crewmembers as
it eats as it expresses how much it
knows about them and about their their
dark secrets in their past that people
shouldn't know that nobody should know
and that we don't even get a full
explanation of it's all fantastic stuff
and it builds really well and again
there's another one that I love this or
I would've liked to have put it higher
except that ultimately once we see it
while I do think that the Beast is very
well realized it does make it a little
less viscerally scary because we see it
and we can wrap our head around and go
oh so that's what it is
so that's why it's not higher but I do
still I love this episode and I do think
it ratchets up the tension really well
number 5 world enough and time this is a
completely different kind of scary
because this is just getting under your
in creepy on a conceptual level and I my
hat has to go off to this episode for
making Cybermen creepy and for really
delving into something that the show as
a whole new especially has kind of
skimmed over which is just how unnerving
the concept of the Cybermen are they
they kind of get played up more as just
a generic robotic enemy but the fact
that these were once people and that the
process that is gone through especially
with these early versions to convert
them is horrifying
I remember the skin crawling on the back
of my neck when bill goes into this this
hospital wing and she goes up to this
one and she adjust this thing that a
nurse had been messing with earlier and
you think it's like some sort of maybe
it's a painkiller she's messing with but
it's just a volume knob and the guy's
just going kill me kill me kill me over
and over and all the nurse did was turn
the volume down and the whole idea that
this is going to be a horrific existence
but people are going to do it just so
they can they continue to exist and that
there really aren't ways to make it less
horrific just things that they can add
to make you not care as much that it is
a horrific terrible existence that's
it's disturbing not just because of the
body horror aspect but the idea of what
human beings are willing to allow to
happen to themselves into their society
just for the sake of continuing to exist
that's an unnerving concept and it's
well handled here number four the other
one that I'm gonna get some hassle on
for it not being further up on the list
blink blink is another one that works
really well now this is one that again
probably the reason it's not higher on
the list is that it doesn't have an
inherent fear factor for me the own the
notion of these statues that move it's a
little creepy subtle on the way it's a
good idea but again it doesn't sort of
hit my personal fear buttons quite as
hard however the execution on this is
darn near flawless it's
possibly a little bit jump-scare heavy
just because of the nature of how the
the weeping angels move but it works
here and and it works as jump scares
because you get the jump of uh it's
there but then it's frozen and it's just
there and so it really doesn't sort of
let you live in the in that fear moment
for a while a lot more than a jump scare
would usually do and then of course the
whole way the narrative plays out as we
don't really know what the deal with
these angels are and we see them move
long before we have any concept of what
is going on with them and it's just
disturbing and then we find out more
about them like oh well that's not
pleasant and you know they're moving in
so never and then when we finally see
the very nasty faces from them which is
only towards the end that we see them
pull those out oh yeah really really
well executed with number three we are
going to get to a creature that on a
conceptual level bears a lot of
similarities to the weeping angels but
this is a case where for me remember I
said the weeping angels didn't quite hit
my own buttons this one does and that's
the silence which means we are talking
about The Impossible Astronaut and day
of the Moon I find the silence very very
unnerving and not infer initially a part
of it is a similar thing to the weeping
angels which is that if you stop looking
at them you're you're completely doomed
the mechanics of it are a little bit
different but the gimmick is effectively
the same but the way in which it works
to me is fundamentally more unnerving
because I find it more disturbing this
idea of as long as you're not looking at
this thing you don't even remember it
messing with somebody mentally is
something that really kind of gets under
my own skin the idea that you cannot
count on your own brain on your own
memory on your own thought process that
they've been turned against you or they
don't work and additionally in this case
you won't even know that you won't have
a hope of even realizing that that is
really unnerving to me and I love
the look of these things I love the way
that they're that they're framed and the
shot and lit and design if I had one
criticism like I think the whole
lightning thing that they do is
unnecessary and I think they actually
would have been even scarier if we
didn't even know what they were capable
of aside from the whole memory-wipe
thing that maybe they could do all sorts
of this stuff but we don't even know we
just sort of know that they're there and
we know like how widespread their and
the ubiquity of them but we don't I
think it would have worked better if we
didn't see anything more that they could
actually do otherwise honestly this
would have had a shot at the top spot at
least for me and what gets under my skin
but it doesn't so let's get to number
two the empty child and the doctor
dances probably the single monster
villain thing that creeped me out more
than anything else in Doctor Who to date
are you my mummy the empty child is so
disturbing to me for so many reasons
first of all the look that gas masks is
immediately iconic and yet wonderfully
mysterious because you have no idea
what's under there could be anything
under there it could in fact be a small
boy it could be something that bears no
resemblance to a small boy whatsoever
but then this is one of the rare cases
where learning more about it actually
makes it scarier and that almost never
happens because generally the more you
learn about something the more you can
wrap your head around it the less
frightened you are of it but for me at
least when we realize that this
ultimately was just a small child trying
to find its mother and that is in fact
at in its essence what it was that made
this all the more scary and all the more
disturbing to me there is something
really terrifying to me about this idea
of a child that has the power to destroy
almost everything it touches but a
probably doesn't realize that and B
doesn't understand the world enough and
under
cause and effect and consequences of its
actions enough to understand why it has
to stop what it's doing because the only
thing that matters to a child as young
as this is is where's my mother and the
fact that it could tear the world apart
and probably would never even realize
that this is a problem because at the
age that this that this child was when
it became the empty child its priorities
are get me my mother and it's gonna
destroy the world to do it and that to
me this idea of something so powerful
and so damaging with them not even the
complete man with the fractured mind of
a child I find that really unnerving and
really disturbing and really really
scary but it doesn't take the number one
spot now I have a feeling if you've been
paying attention you might have figured
out what the number one is cuz what's
something that I've brought up over and
over and over again uncertainty the
unknown the less we know the scarier it
is so that means that from my money the
scariest episode of New Era doctor who
has to be midnight because we don't know
what that thing was we don't know what
its goals world we don't know how really
it did anything it did and that makes it
unnerving and bonus on this it's not
just the midnight entity it's not just
the monster that is scary it also does
with so many great horror stories do
which is to make the humans scary as
well the people are part of the problem
they are just as dangerous if not more
so than this thing that we don't even
understand what it is and how it works
and just watching it progress as it cuz
I mean initially they're you know having
something repeat your words back to you
that's just annoying but that is the it
starts closing the gap and then one is
speaking at the same time of the doctor
and then that moment
when it's ahead of him and it's just
that is such a wonderful moment
perfectly built up to perfectly executed
wonderfully tense the instant this thing
is introduced into the setting until it
is go even after it's gone you're still
because you don't know what it was
you're still going and that is why from
my money midnight is the scariest
episode of new whoo
so those are my thoughts that's my list
what are your thoughts do you have a
list you want to throw out there
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter I
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher I am also one half
of leap punch like a girl podcast
available on the fire and water Network
Fire and Water podcast calm until next
time this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]